alors bonjour donc je suis la preuve de
la chaîne youtube chronique de profs
donc il parle d'histoire principalement
et donc moi je vais vous parler du roman
national c'est à dire en gros la manière
dont on a pu écrire l'histoire à travers
le temps et donc le roman national c'est
à définir la manière dont on écrivait
l'histoire au 19e siècle mais on va un
petit peu développée sur les autres
périodes quand j'étais en licence
j'avais une amie de lycée qui m'avait
dit à force tu dois tout savoir sur
l'histoire parce que pour elle comme
j'ai étudié l'histoire je devais tout
connaître et je pense qu'elle disait ça
parce qu'elle envisageait l'histoire
comme une succession de dates des deux
personnages un petit peu comme ça et
forcément si on s'en tient cette vision
on peut assez rapidement se dire c'est
bon je sais toute l'histoire je peux
tout gagné au trivial pursuit c'est fini
et donc cette manière d'enseigner
l'histoire c'est plutôt celle qu'on
avait au 19e siècle
on l'a connu un petit peu quand on était
en école primaire pour certains cantons
étudié vercingétorix le vase de soissons
etc
et elle nous vient d'une époque où on
met en place l'école gratuite laïque et
obligatoire
on réfléchit à une manière de mettre en
place de mettre en valeur l'héritage
français demain à travers des
personnages importants des événements
emblématiques qui montre la grandeur du
pays alors ernest lavisse écrit un
manuel scolaire à cette époque et pour
lui l'histoire s'apprend par le choeur
les personnages qu'on étudie sont des
héros nationaux dont je vous ai mis une
petite citation de son livre il faut
aimer la france et pour ça on illustre
sa part des héros nationaux ont
plusieurs raisons expliquent la mise en
place de cette ce type d'histoire la
première c'est une raisons religieuses
à l'époque les la plupart des écoles
sont tenus par des congrégations
religieuses et ça ne plaît pas trop à
l'état à la troisième république qui a
été mis en place depuis assez peu de
temps et donc on décide de faire fermer
ses écoles pour pouvoir ouvrir des
écoles républicaines dans lesquels on
enseignera ce qu'on veut
la deuxième raison c'est aussi qu'on
veut former de bons citoyens en 1848 a
été mis en place ce suffrage universel
masculin et donc les français ont pu
voter et ils ont voté pour napoléon iii
qui a mis fin à la république qui a mis
en place le second empire donc les
français ont voté
pour quelqu'un qui a mis fin à la
république qui leur avait permis de
voter c'est un petit peu ballot et c'est
pour ça qu'on veut éviter ça en
permettant aux français d'avoir une
meilleure culture républicaine et la
troisième raison enfin c'est que pendant
la guerre de 1870
les français ont perdu contre les
prussiens et on considère ce qui n'est
pas forcément vrai mais à l'époque c'est
ce qu'on pense que les français ont été
battus parce qu'ils étaient moins
patriote que les prussiens et parce
qu'il s'y connaissait moins bien en
histoire et en géographie
donc c'est pour ça qu'on veut mettre en
place une école qui met en avant l'unité
nationale du pays
pour ça on utilise l'exemple des gaulois
mais aussi l'unité religieuse pour ça on
va parler du baptême de clovis et aussi
de l'exemple de jeanne d'arc
la vision de l'histoire qu'avaient les
élèves au 19e siècle et c'est donc
biaisé incomplète et parfois
complètement inventée par exemple les
gaulois qu'on imaginait bagarreur
sauvage et vivent dans la forêt et une
vision un petit peu décalé par rapport à
la réalité
cette manière d'enseigner l'histoire
dans les écoles correspond à l'école
historique méthodique
alors l'école méthodique c'est un
courant historiographique
l'historiographie c'est l'histoire de
l'histoire où l'histoire de comment on
écrit l'histoire est donc ça c'est un
courant historiographique du 19e siècle
dont je vous ai mis l'exemple de deux
personnages emblématiques pour l'école
méthodique comme pour les programmes de
l'époque on s'intéresse aux biographique
aux politiques à l'événementiel et
surtout aux sources écrites on
s'intéresse assez peu aux autres sources
alors que maintenant on est un peu plus
diversifiée et dès 1903 cette école est
critique et donc par françois 6 millions
dans les trois idoles de la tribu des
historiens qui considère que l'école
méthodique et politiques individuelles
et chronologique donc à nouveau
biographique événementiel etc
pour lui ça n'est pas très bien parce
qu'il faudrait essayer un petit peu plus
de contextualiser d'élargir un petit peu
son propos alors pour ça je vais partir
sur deux exemples
par exemple dans le dimanche de bouvines
de georges duby qu'ils aient paru en
on a une histoire d'une bataille donc
c'est bien l'histoire événementielle
mais dans son livre il s'efforce de
montrer le contexte pourquoi il ya cette
bataille comment est-ce que ça s'est
passé qu'elle était la sauce
et l époque qui a mené à cette bataille
un deuxième exemple passent par la micro
histoire qui a un autre courant
historiographique plutôt des années
1960-70 donc là dans la micro histoire
on s'intéresse à un individu
complètement anonymes ou un cas banal
une affaire judiciaire à peu oublié et à
partir de là on s'efforce de montrer la
société de l'époque donc là alain corbin
a pris dans les archives une commune au
hasard dans cette commune il a pris un
personnage au hasard et il en a fait la
biographie donc on s'est retrouvé avec
la biographie de louis françois pin à jo
qui était sabotier à origny le butin au
19e siècle et à partir de là il montre
le monde rural de la france au 19e
siècle
ça c'est de la micro histoire et c'est
un autre une autre forme de courant
historique
là j'ai fait un bond en avant mais tout
ça pour dire que l'histoire du style nos
ancêtres les gaulois ne fait pas long
feu dans la recherche historique au 20e
siècle
par contre dans les programmes elle
reste un peu plus longtemps donc
maintenant on va s'intéresser aux
différents programmes qui ont pu se
succéder et qui suivent plus ou moins
les recherches historiques des années
1880 à 1955 on reste dans le roman
national dans une histoire plutôt
traditionnelle de la france mais à
partir de la deuxième guerre mondiale
on sort d'un conflit qui a bouleversé
toute l'europe aider les autres
continents et on commence donc à
s'intéresser aux civilisations
étrangères ça serait peut-être bien de
s'intéresser à ses voisins pour ne pas
reproduire ça donc on introduit dans les
programmes d études sur des sociétés
extra européenne ensuite à partir des
années 70 on a une nouvelle approche de
l'histoire qui est plus thématiques par
exemple on étudie la naissance et le
développement des villes ou encore
l'évolution des navires et des
transports maritimes
donc là on fait plus une histoire qu'ils
aillent d'un point a à un point b on
s'intéresse à des thèmes qu'on développe
un peu plus ensuite dans les années 80
par contre là on a un retour en arrière
puisque on était parti sur une histoire
forte et matic sa perte sur certaines
personnes qui se disent mais on fait
plus l'histoire traditionnel qu'est ce
qui se passe
et donc il ya une une du figaro qui date
des années 70 80 où il était écrit
français on n'enseigne plus l'histoire à
vos enfants
ça fait peur on écrit de nouveaux
programmes et dans ses nouveaux
programmes
on met à nouveau en avant une culture
commune une culture républicaine
nationale et aussi européenne
et c'est là qu'on remet en place
également l'éducation civique donc cette
culture commune d'assat on retrouve un
petit peu le roman national d'autant
plus qu'à cette époque on a de plus en
plus d'enfants issus de l'immigration
dans les classes et on veut qu'ils
adhèrent aussi à cette culture commune
et enfin dans les années 95
cette fois on a un nouveau revirement
avec les notions qui apparaissent de
mémoire de patrimoine et de devoir de
mémoire notamment en lien avec la
seconde guerre mondiale la mémoire de la
shoah et avec la guerre d'algérie donc
on multiplie les commémorations les
créations de musées les événements les
monuments et tout ça se ressent dans les
programmes par exemple on avait nicolas
sarkozy qui avait voulu mettre en place
la lecture de la lettre de guy môquet
dans tous les lycées
ça c'est typiquement un exemple de
l'usaj de la mémoire dans les cours
d'histoire donc les programmes actuels
mélange un petit peu tout ça dans
primaire on a un retour de repères
classiques
alors on étudie alésia on aborde le
baptême de clovis
par contre au collège on a une ouverture
vers d'autres civilisations
par exemple en sixième on étudie l'inde
et la chine ancienne
en 5e on étudie les royaumes africains
médiévaux et au lycée on peut avoir
certaines études plus thématiques à
nouveau sur un temps long par exemple
sur les médias et l'opinion publique
depuis l' affaire dreyfus donc surtout
le long du xxème siècle alors on a comme
ça des approches très différentes on qui
peut du coup rendre un petit peu confuse
la manière d'enseigner l'histoire aux
élèves puissent qu'ils étudient des
des types d'histoires différents en
fonction de la primaire du collège et du
lycée
je me suis pas seulement attardé sur le
roman national dans cette présentation
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
l'écriture de l'histoire évolue tout le
temps pas seulement en fonction des
événements mais aussi en fonction de
l'intérêt des historiens pour tel ou tel
type d'histoire et également des enjeux
politiques derrière l'écriture de
l'histoire et des programmes scolaires
voilà donc si vous voulez me retrouver
bon j'ai pas mis de petits logos comme
personne avant mais j'ai une chaîne qui
s'appelle chronique de profs dans
laquelle je fais les tas de vidéos
historiques et je vais laisser la parole
à la personne suivante